can i ask you about testing
sure
sure so you mentioned pcr what kind of
tests are there the antigen test
uh what what are your thoughts on each
maybe this is a good place to uh to also
mention like viral load
and um
the history of the virus as it passes
through your body in terms of the
okay
what's being tested for and all those
kinds of things
so the
the first tests that were developed
were
pcr polymerase chain reaction they're
basically nucleic acid amplification
tests
and they were very first ones they stuck
the swab all the way up into your brain
almost
you know i had that done a couple of
weeks ago oh my gosh it's really nasty
but now they do an anterior nary swab
they get a little
they get a bunch of cells and some mucus
which has virus and
parts of virus stick it in a test tube
and then they run a reaction which by
the way involves reverse transcriptase
because it converts the viral rna to dna
and then you amplify it
and you can specify what part of the
viral rna you want to amplify and then a
machine will detect it
and it can be done in 15 minutes
but you're detecting pieces of rna not
infectious virus so we're measuring
viral rna loads right
and a common
mistake that many people who should know
better you know physicians and
scientists of all kinds
they think that indicates how much virus
you have
it doesn't
it it's a diagnostic of whether you have
bits of rna in you and it
probably means you're infected but
you can't use it to shed light on what's
going on and i'll tell you why in a bit
but first we have to explain some other
things
so until you get to about a million
copies
of rna so you can measure the copy
number in this test this pcr test
it's it's a number called ct or cycle
threshold the test the way the machine
works it goes through cycles in every
cycle it amplifies
what you put in
and
the more cycles you need to see
something that means there's not a lot
of rna there
so if you see a if you do a test and you
have a cycle threshold of 35
you have very little rna in you
contrary if you have a cycle threshold
of 10 you have a ton of rna it only took
10 cycles to detect it
and you can extrapolate from that number
the number of copies you have per sample
say per swap and if you don't have a
million you're not infectious
you're not going to infect anyone so in
the early days no matter what ct whatev
what pcr result you had they would
quarantine you and that was wrong
because you're not shedding you don't
need to be quarantined but but
wasn't thought through properly right
that's where you had like 14 days or
something like that
which is now we know is too long because
you don't shed for that long in a normal
infection now it's 10 days should be
fine
so what happens is you get infected you
don't know it of course the virus starts
to grow very quickly and within four or
five days you reach a peak
of shedding you're making a lot of rna
and you may be asymptomatic you're
shedding it can affect others and then
you may or may not have your symptom
onset
so you shed for a couple of days before
symptoms and then within three days four
days
the viral rna crashes and you're no
longer shedding you're no longer
transmitting so that's the one kind of
test we have it can tell you if you're
infected at the moment
but it won't tell you if you're going to
be infected tomorrow right because if
you're negative today you could be
positive tomorrow you just might be on
in a different part of the incubation
period right
so that's one test
been used the most you can now
get 15-minute versions of them in a
walk-in or whatever fine then they're
antigen tests which look for the
proteins that the virus is making so as
it's reproducing in your nose it's not
only making genomes it's making proteins
and so these you can buy in the
drugstore
and
these would have been great if they had
you know michael minna last year had the
idea that if we could make a little
stick a little piece of paper that you
would suck on and it would tell you if
you're infected or not if this could
cost less than a buck
everybody could test which they can cost
less than a buck by the way
yeah but they were never made right
right
uh
they're never mass manufactured so his
idea is to do like daily tests so yeah
daily and then a kid's going to school
he's positive or she's positive
well if it's cheap enough you just take
another test because they have a certain
error frequency if it's positive twice
you stay home and the next day you try
again
and this i think this would have
revolutionized because the pcr tests are
more expensive at the time and they take
longer to do and so forth
but uh that never happened but now we do
have twenty dollar binax now and others
that you can buy and people buy them and
see but that can still happen right and
this is a very frustrating thing to me
because
i'm worried about variance but i'm also
worried about future much more deadly
pandemics
like
and i know we kind of said yes covey
lots of deaths
but like it could be a lot worse
too
so i'm thinking
what is going to be the right response
for the future
pandemic of its kind and what's the
right response for continued number of
variants and some of the variants might
be deadlier
or more transmissible well we we can the
antigen
tests
will pick up the variance that's not a
question the pcr may be influenced by
changes but you can quickly adapt the
primers that you use that's what i mean
like to me all these discussions about
vaccines and so on
vaccines we got very lucky that they
took so little time right
and and you have to be aware no matter
what that there's hesitancy with the
vaccines in this country before i mean
yeah if that's a reality you can't just
be like magically saying that
right you're going to overcome that
and i don't think there's any hesitancy
and cheap tests at home i agree i think
if someone so the question is if someone
tested positive would they stay home
that's the question what if their what
if their job depends on them going in i
i mean that's well you have to look at
sort of
aggregate
yeah how many people would decide
and i think
um
again a lot of that is in leadership but
i think a lot of them
i would say most people stay home
i think
that mina had the idea and it would have
changed the whole
situation for sure if it could have been
made when we talked to him last spring i
think or summer
we would have gotten around a lot of the
issues that we're in today because i
think people would have stayed home and
not transmitted and i think it's still
valuable to this day in the fall if we
don't have vaccine uptake we could just
test kids every day yeah and get and
keep them home when they're infected it
cuts
it's
and we don't have it
but i think and i'm not privy to what
was going on but
i don't think a lot of emphasis was put
on testing early on you know the cdc
developed the first one it was flawed
they had to recall the kits i mean
there's a fiasco they should have had
100 companies making the tests initially
right
so for the future
i think what we have learned is we need
to have a rapid antigen test right off
the bat
that's doable
you can't do it in a day like you can
for pcr
because you need to make antibodies to
the protein that you're looking for and
you need to do those in animals but you
can do it in weeks
and we should be ready for that
you